[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف
لها نغم يحس به الشغوف
يرى فيها غصونا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
واذا تناسبت الرجال فما اراه نسبا يقاس
بصالح الاعمال واذا بحثت عن التقي وجدته
رجلا يصدق قوله بفعاله السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
اذا كان الوفاء من نبيل الصفات ومحاسن
النعوت فان الغدر من ذميمها ومكروها نقول
غدر يغدر غدرا اذا نقض العهد ورجل غادر
وغدار وغدير وغدور ويقال للمراه غادره
وغداره وغدور الحيوان الغادر الذي يهاجم
غدرا على حين غفله ويقال غدر الليل اي
اظلم وغدرت المراه وليدها اي اساءت غذائه
وغدر اي كثير الغدر والخيانه وفي حديث
الحديبيه كما تعرفون قال عروه بن مسعود
للمغيره بن شعبه اي غدر وهل غسلت سوءتك
الا بالامس وكان المغيره قد صحب قوما في
الجاهليه فقتلهم وسرق اموالهم ثم جاء
فاسلم
يقول ابو الطيب المتنبي
اتلتمس الاعداء بعد الذي رات قيام دليل او
وضوح بياني رات كل من ينوي لك الغدر يبتلى
بغدر حياه او بغدر زماني
[موسيقى]
قال الجاحظ في رسائله فمن كان معروفا
بالوفاء في اوقات الشده وحالات الضروره
فنافس فيه واسبق اليه فان اعتقاده انفس
العقد ومن بلاه غيرك فكشف عن كفر النعمه
والغدر عند الشده فقد حذرك نفسه وان انسك
وكما غدر بغيرك يغدر بك فان من شيمته
الوفاء يفي للصديق والعدو ومن طبيعته
الغدر لا يفي لاحد وانما يميل مع الرجحان
يذل عند الحاجه ويشمخ مع الاستغناء
وفي هذا المعنى يقول البارودي
ادهى المصائب غدر قبله وثقه واقبح الظلم
صد بعد اقبال وقالوا اذا ذهب الوفاء نزل
البلاء واذا ظهرت الخيانات
استمحقت البركات
استمحقت اي بمحلت وقيل الوفاء من شيم
الكرام والغدر من همم اللئام
وكان يحيى ابن خالد اذا اجتهد في يمينه
يقول لا والذي جعل الوفاء اعز ما يرى
وجربنا وجرب اولونا فما شيء اعز من الوفاء
وقد قال القديم وفيت بادرع الكندي اني اذا
ما خان اقوام وفيت كنت اسمع كبار السن في
بلدتنا يقولون من امنك لا تخنه ولو كنت
خوانا
[موسيقى]
من طرائف القدماء ان رجلا خطب الى قوم
فجاؤوا الى الشعبي يسالونه عنه وكان به
عارفا فقال والله ما علمت الا انه نافذ
الطعنه ركين الجلسه فزوجوه فاذا هو خياط
فاتوا الشعبي وقالوا غررتنا فقال ما فعلت
وانه لكما وصفت
والشيء بشيء يذكر اخذ عسس الحجاج ثلاثه
فتيه يتجولون ليلا ويتمايلون عليهم اثر
الشراب فقيل لهم من انتم حتى خالفتم امر
الامير وخرجتم ليلا فقال الاول انا ابن
الذي لها ينزل الدهر قدره وان نزلت يوما
فسوف تعود ترى الناس افواجا الى ضوء ناره
فمنهم قيام حولها وقعود
فامسك عنه العسس وقالوا لعله من اقارب
الامير ثم قال الثاني انا ابن من دانه
الرقاب له ما بين مخزومها وهاشمها تاتي
اليه الرقاب صاغره ياخذ من مالها ومن دمها
فامسك عنه العسس وقالوا لعله من اشراف
العرب ثم قال الثالث انا ابن الذي خاض
الصفوف بعزمه
وقومها بالسيف حتى استقامتي
ركاباه لا تنفك رجلاه منهما اذا الخيل في
يوم الكريهه والتي
فامسكوا عنه وقالوا لعله من فوارس العرب
وشجعانهم
فلما رفعوا امرهم الى الحجاج احضرهم وكشف
عن حالهم فاذا الاول ابوه طباخ والثاني
ابوه حجام والثالث ابوه حائك فتعجب الحجاج
من فصاحتهم وقال لجلسائه علموا اولادكم
الادب والله لولا فصاحتهم لضربت اعناقهم
وقد قال القديم كن ابن من شئت واكتسب ادبا
يغنيك محموده عن النسب
[موسيقى]
لا تقل هوام الارض بميم مخففه قل هوام
والارض بتشديد الميم الواحده هامه سميت
بذلك من الهميم وهو الدبيب
لا تقل اعوذ بالله من طوارق الليل والنهار
قل اعوذ بالله من طوارق الليل لان الطروق
هو الاتيان بالليل خاصه
[موسيقى]
يقول المثل انا ابن بجدتها فما هي البجده
وما قصه المثل
انا ابن بشدتها اي انا عالم بها والهاء
راجعه على الارض يقال عنده بجده ذاك اي
علم ذاك وبجد بالمكان اذا اقام به ومن
اقام بموضع علم ذلك الموضع ويقال البجده
التراب فكان قولهم ابن بجدتها اي مخلوق من
ترابها يقول كعب بن زهير فيها ابن بجدتها
يكاد يذيبه وقد النهار اذا استنار الصيف
[موسيقى]
سالتكم في تويتر عن اجمل شعر قيل في
التوسل الى الله تعالى وفيما يلي استعرض
معكم بعض ما وصلني من مشاركاتكم هذه
مشاركه من عبد الحافظ السماوي يقول لبست
ثوبه دجى والناس قد رقدوا وقمت اشكو الى
مولاي ما اجد وقلت يا عدتي في كل نائبه
ومن عليه لكشف الضر اعتمد اشكو اليك امورا
انت تعلمها مالي على حملها صبر ولا جلد
فقد مددت يدي بالذل مبتهلا اليك يا خير من
مده اليه يد
مشاركه من امجد عارف يقول مولاي اني ببابك
قد بسطت يدي
مليوذ به الا كي يا سندي
وطبعا هذا البيت لو سمعتموه بصوت
النقشبندي لذهبتم الى عالم اخر
عبد الله يقول
مالي سوى قرعي لبابك حيله فلان رددت فاي
باب اقرعوا يا من خزائن رزقه في قولكن امن
فان الخير عندك اجمع
ومشاركه من ابراهيم علي يقول وقول ابي
نواس يا رب ان عظمت ذنوبي كثره فلقد علمت
بان عفوك اعظم ان كان لا يرجوك الا محسن
فبمن يلوذ ويستجير المجرم
محمد ابراهيم الهواري يقول ولما قسى قلبي
وضاقت مذاهبي جعلت الرجا مني لعفوك سلما
تعاظمني ذنبي فلما قرنته بعفوك ربي كان
عفوك اعظم
صالح قباده يقول الهي ليس لي احد سواك انا
بشر ولم اخلق ملاك تراودني المعاصي غير
اني اباعدها واطمع في رضاك
وخطاب الجبوري ساق بيتا للبحتري يقول اذا
محاسني اللاتي ادل بها كانت ذنوبي فقل لي
كيف اعتذر
اذا مشاركه ايضا من
النور يقول رباه ان الروح ترجو رحمه تاه
الطريق فيا الهي دلها ضاقت بها الدنيا
وبابك مشرع ان لم تكن انت المغيث فملها
الله
ومشاركه من بدر يقول ناجى اعرابي ربه فقال
اليك بك اتوسل ومنك اليك اثر
واختم بهذه المشاركه لعبد الله الهاجري
يقول
ان الملوك اذا شابت عبيدهم في رقهم
اعتقوهم عتق ابراري وانت يا خالقي اولى
بنا كرما قد جبت في الرق فاعتقني من النار
اذا بهذه المشاركه اصل معكم الى ختام فقره
واسم اشكر لكم هذه المشاركات الجميله
واذكركم دائما بان تضعوا اسم تاملات
الجزيره عند نهايه كل مشاركه
[موسيقى]
هذا الذي تعرف البطحاء وطاته والبيت يعرفه
والحل والحرم اذا راته قريش قال قائلها
الى مكارم هذا ينتهي الكرم عن قائل هذه
الابيات احدثكم الفرزدق
همام ابن غالب بن صعصعه التميمي حفيد
صعصعه بن ناجيه الذي اشتهر قبل الاسلام
بافتداء الموؤودات ثم ادرك الاسلام واشتهر
بالجود والكرم اما ابوه غالب ابن صعصعه
فقد روي انه وفد على علي بن ابي طالب كرم
الله وجهه ايام خلافته ومعه الفرزدق وهو
غلام يومئذ فقال امير المؤمنين من الشيخ
قال انا غالب بن صعصعه قال ذو الابل
الكثيره قال نعم قال ما فعلت ابلوك قال
اذهبتها النوائب وذاعتها الحقوق
فقال علي ذاك احمد سبلها ثم ساله من هذا
الغلام معك قال ولدي وقد رويته الشعر يا
امير المؤمنين وكلام العرب ويوشك ان يكون
شاعرا مجيدا فقال له علي كرم الله وجهه لو
اقراته القران فهو خير له فكان الفرزدق
بعد ذلك يروي هذا الحديث ويقول ما زالت
كلمته في نفسي حتى قيد الفرزدق نفسه بقيد
والا الا يفكه حتى يحفظ القران فما فكه
حتى حفظه وربما كانت هذه القصه بدايه
ارتباطه بال البيت هذا الارتباط الذي لم
يمنعه وللاؤه لبني اميه من مدحهم فقد روي
ان الفرزدق حج مع هشام بن عبد الملك قبل
ان يلي هشام الخلافه
وكان الحج مزدحما فاجتهد هشام ان يستلم
الحجر الاسود فلم يتمكن ثم جاء علي بن
الحسين المعروف بزين العابدين فافسح له
الحجيج حتى استلم الحجر فسال هشام من هذا
ولم يكن يعرفه فرد الفرزدق بهذه القصيده
مادحا عليا
هذا الذي تعرف البطحاء وطاته والبيت يعرفه
والحل والحرم اذا راته قريش قال قائلها
الى مكارم هذا ينتهي الكرم ان عد اهل
التقى كانوا ائمتهم او قيل من خير اهل
الارض قيلهم هذا ابن فاطمه ان كنت تجهله
بجده انبياء الله قد ختموا ما قال لا قط
الا في تشهده لولا التشهد كانت لا اهو نعم
وليس قولك من هذا بضائره العرب تعرف من
انكرت والعجم
اما قصه زواج الفرزدق من ابنه عمه النوارب
بنت اعين ابن صعصعه التي ملكت عليه قلبه
فهي من الطرافه بمكان فقد تزوجها بحيله
كما يروي صاحب الاغاني في كتابه
خطبها رجل من بني عبد الله بن دار فرضيته
وكان الفرزدق وليها فارسلت الى الفرزدق ان
زوجني من هذا الرجل فقال
اوتشهدينني انك قد رضيت بمن زوجتك قالت
نعم فلما توثق منها قال ارسلي الى القوم
فلياتوا فجاء بنو عبد الله بن دارم
فاجتمعوا بمسجد بني مجاشع وجاء الفرزدق
فحمد الله واثنى عليه ثم قال قد علمتم ان
النوار قد ولتني امرها واشهدكم اني قد
زوجتها نفسي على مئه ناقه حمراء سوداء
الحدقه
فنفرت من ذلك وارادت الشخوص الى ابن
الزبير حين اعياها اهل البصره ان لا
يطلقوها من الفرزدق حتى يشهد لها الشهود
وطبعا اعياها الشهود ان يشهدوا اتقاء
الفرزدق ابن الزبير يومئذ امير الحجاز
والعراق يدعى له بالخلافه لكنها لم تجد من
يحملها فاتت فتيه من بني عدي بن عبد منات
يقال لهم بنو ام النسيم فسالتهم برحم
تجمعهم واياها وكانت بينها وبينهم قرابه
فحملوها فبلغ ذلك الفرزدق فاستنهض عده من
اهل البصره فانهضوه واوقروا له الابل
واتبع النوار وقال في ذلك
اطاعت بني ام النسيم فاصبحت على شارف
وارقى اصعب ذلولها وان الذي امسى يخبب
زوجتي
كماشا الى اسد الشرى يستبيلها
فادركها وقد قدمت مكه فاستجرت بخوله بنت
منظور امراه عبد الله بن الزبير فاجارتها
خوله
خرج الفرزدق فهذا بحمزه بن عبد الله بن
الزبير فاجاره وقال الفرزدق ويمدحه
يا حمزه هل لك في ذي حاجه غرضت امضاءه
بمكان غير ممطوري فانت اولى قريش ان تكون
لها وانت بين ابي بكر ومنظوري فجعل امر
النوار يقوى وامر الفرزدق يضعف فقال
الفرزدق في ذلك اما بنوه فلم تنفع شفاعتهم
وشفعت بنت منظور بن زبانه ليس الشفيع الذي
ياتي كمؤتذرا مثل الشفيع الذي ياتيك
عريانا
فبلغ ابن الزبير شعره ولقيه على باب
المسجد وهو خارج منه فضغط حلقه حتى كاد
يقتله ثم خلاه ثم دخل الى النوار فقال لها
ان شئت فرقت بينك وبينه ثم ضربت عنقه فلا
يهجون ابدا وان شئت امضيت نكاحه فهو ابن
عمك واقرب الناس اليك
وكانت امراه صالحه فقالت وما غير هذا قال
لا قالت ما احب ان يقتل ولكني امضي امره
فلعل الله ان يجعل في كرهي اياه خيرا
فمضت اليه وخرجت معه الى البصره يقول
الفرزدق خرجنا ونحن متباغضان فعدنا
متحابين فلما اصطلح ورضيت به ساق اليها
مهرها ودخل بها قبل ان يخرج من مكه ثم عاد
الى البصره فمكثا ما شاء الله واصبح له
منها اولاد وبنات ولكن ما لم تستطع النوار
ان تحققه بمعونه السلطان والحكام والامراء
وصلت اليه بالحيله والدها فما زالت تتودد
اليه حتى وافق على طلاقها واشترط عليها ان
تبقي له الاعطيات وان لا تتزوج بعده فقبلت
على ان يشهد طلاقهما الحسن البصري فاتيا
الحسن فقال له الفرزدق يا ابا سعيد قال له
الحسن ما تشاء قال اشهد ان النوار طالق
ثلاثا فقال الحسن
قد شهدناه وندم الفرزدق على طلاقها ذلك
ندما شديدا قال فيه
ندمت ندامه الكسعي لما غدت مني مطلقه
النوار ولو اني ملكت يدي وقلبي لكان علي
للقدر اختيار
وكانت جنتي فخرجت منها كادم حين اخرجهم
ضرار وكنت كفاقع عينيه عمدا فاصبح ما يضيء
له النهار
[موسيقى]
اتى ايلول قل الغيمه امتلئ قل للظل ان
يبقى مكان المقعد الصديق اتى ايلول
واغتربت عيوني فيكي
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]